cette année les gilles du salon est une
vache de race charolaise c'est idéal
mais le saviez vous en france une vache
sur deux dans un troupeau est de race
charolaise
mais c'est aussi la première race à
viande en france
[Musique]
je suis en gaec avec mon mari nous
exploitons 280 hectares et faisons vais
les 150 vaches charolaises inscrits ce
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous de
venir au salon de l'agriculture
alors cette année
nous avons la race charolaise à
l'honneur donc nous mettons déjà en
avant notre race donc ici avec lanzarote
et son veau alors une bonne charolaise
elle a un bon a bondi de culotte du dos
une bonne gueule je dirais avec des
cornes blanchet et une bonne largeur de
mufle à la charolaise
docile elle s'adapte sur tous les
terrains et chacun met en valeur les
qualités qu'ils préconisent certains
préconisent plus le développement
d'autres plus muscles voilà chacun fait
ses choix
ça peut paraître étonnant mais le salon
de l'agriculture ce n'est pas que les
grosses bêtes ya aussi les petites bêtes
on a rendez vous tout de suite avec une
éleveuse de charbon
[Musique]
je viens d'une ville d'apt nuage entre
beaune et dijon savez les bars
donc c'est la troisième année que je
suis sélectionné pour le salon de
l'agriculture
qu'est ce que ça vous apporte vous de
venir au salon de l'agriculture
vous voyez regarder tout le monde
qu'elle a en fin de compte ça faire
reconnaître notre race qui est super
important
qu'est ce que vous disent les gens quand
ils viennent vous voir ici
ah bah ils sont super contents de voir
un
des chats grâce des chats
johannie michaud ne partent pas chez
n'importe qui ça c'est sûr
des conditions alors il faut qu'ils
un milieu stable que les gens soient pas
absent toute la journée
et que
pas dans st
la carne ou quoi que ce soit
qu'ils puissent vivre leur vie de chat
correctement
je
il